[Música]
pudiera yo referirme al celaya
de los años 50 cuando yo era niño
y las puertas estaban abiertas y vías el
canario y las macetas y el piso limpias
y tu hermosísimo lo podemos seguir
viendo eso hoy
cómo podría yo referir a las cifras que
vemos en los periódicos de los muertos
diariamente y entonces tendríamos que
llegar a un tema que nos preocupa
absolutamente a todos por eso pido
empiezo a cargo gordo porque voy a
entrar en temas no no es decir en ese
tan choteado y tan sobado de la
seguridad sin embargo es real pues una
ilusión
absolutamente real y va haciendo cada
día peor
en la mente de todos nosotros que
ahorita estamos acompañados diciendo que
podemos hacer
sabemos quiénes podemos decir pues así
va a seguir y ya cómo van las cosas
creciendo y creciendo y creciendo nunca
va a parar y otros hay que dicen no si
se tiene que detener de alguna manera
bueno eso es lo que vamos a ver el día
de hoy en esta pequeña presentación
encontré yo soy muy dado al es
particularmente historia temas x y di
con dos frases que me dieron mucha luz
respecto a la cuestión mexicana de la
seguridad por regional o del estado que
ustedes me quieran decir es de un
emperador romano allá de por los años
250 de nuestra era
marco aurelio
y dos frases
una locura perseguir un imposible
en segunda
es imposible
que los perversos no hagan alguna
perversidad
híjole esta pelea agudísimo
como queremos que se acabe la
perversidad en este país si no se está
diciendo marco aurelio que es imposible
y que es una locura atacarla
directamente y las cifras las
estadísticas y los reportes mediáticos
nos dicen que en abril había 750 muertos
unidad eran 820 y el año que entra más y
más y más pregunta con sinceridad ya se
juntaron conmigo en este pensamiento
diga en menos sinceramente por favor si
pueden hablarlo y decir lo que bueno si
no bueno pues piénsenlo si será posible
terminar
con el crimen organizado de mexico
atacándolo con armas
salió medio débil medio aguadilla
pero es real
revel más que nos dice la experiencia se
ha podido
ánimo sobre todo a ti te creo que es muy
optimista y tu plática me gustó mucho
se podrá prevenir
y salió un si se podrá prevenir ahora de
eso se trata precisamente entonces
empecé a buscar quienes están trabajando
en la prevención aunque sea de una
manera modesta o algunos otros de una
manera impresionante como aquellos que
están organizando escuelas quiero decir
si escuelas de música para que los
jovencitos que están en situaciones
difíciles orden una orquesta sinfónica y
lo tenemos en varias partes del país o
escuelas de este tipo y desde otro y hay
algunas acciones de prevención
maravillosas que preparaba yo un listado
de las seis o siete más importantes
aires por ejemplo de la calle a la
cancha de quién es
de la fundación slim y está en todo el
país pero donde encuentro allí en
nuestro lugar en purísima del rincón fue
un ejemplo conmovedor por eso yo me
callo y le pasó la pelota a mauricio
hinojosa ven para acá mucha acción
buenas tardes muchas gracias ramón que
puedan decir qué fácil el señor le pasó
la bolita y se fue a sentar y lo aventó
al matadero no tengo aquí la la pelota
para eso de los que estén ahí con el
shopping tengo muy buena puntería bueno
yo sé morís hinojosa soy orgullosamente
guanajuatenses tengo 25 años soy
empresario había puesto una foto un poco
más en acción pero me dijo mi novia no
está porque se te ve la cara que no sé
qué entonces puse esa este
para mí el deporte para mi vida ha hecho
deporte y estoy muy agradecido con el
deporte me ha formado muchísimo me ha
complementado en información y muchas
relaciones muy valiosas amistades
inclusive viajes que conocía el mundo a
través del deporte por eso les pongo
esta fotografía
dice maría montessori existe una muy
estrecha relación entre el abandono
infantil y el desarrollo posterior de la
delincuencia hace algunos años el
instituto de planeación del estado de
guanajuato un consejo empresarial invitó
a este cuate es un tejano convex el
trabajo con nelson mandela en todo esto
de la parte de lo trajeron para que les
dijera a mediano o largo plazo como
guanajuato podría mejorar
y a la sorpresa de muchos empresarios
que pensaron que les iba a decir
con edificios con vialidades carreteras
y todas estas inversiones
multimillonarias que vemos de los
gobiernos les dijo si quieren ver cómo
será méxico en 20 años voltean a ver qué
están haciendo los niños ahora
todos conocemos los temas de conflicto
en nuestro país la problemática
delincuencia inseguridad narcotráfico
corrupción desigualdad
la semana pasada leí en un artículo de
cada 100 mexicanos que nacen pobres 74
morirán siendo pobres
el índice de deserción escolar es
preocupante si hay más gente que está en
3 universidades que está graduando pero
por otro lado los niños que pasan de
primaria secundaria prácticamente la
mitad se queda en deserción y abandona
sus estudios pobreza
la mitad de los mexicanos son pobres y
la mitad de esos pobres viven en pobreza
extrema
y en cuanto a la drogadicción todos
sabemos los niños
a los 89 años no muy lejos de aquí
purísima del rincón en san francisco en
nuestro estado se empiezan empiezan a
tener acceso a las drogas muy fácilmente
a cada vez más temprana edad no
estamos esperando un cambio y estamos
esperando que alguien haga algo
no hay
no hay una varita mágica no hay una
receta pero si yo he vivido
muy buenas experiencias y creo que hay
una estrategia muy inteligente que es
enfocarnos en un sector primordial
indispensable que son los niños
ustedes y no por favor
hay organizaciones como bien mencionaba
ramón hay empresas socialmente
responsables que ya están
implementando acciones
y enfocándose en la infancia sin embargo
no es suficiente no necesitamos tener
una empresa tener mucho dinero
estudiantes trabajadores padres de
familia todos debemos sumarnos en este
en este problema y tomar la
responsabilidad como equipo
les voy a mostrar un vídeo muy breve
de un centro comunitario que tenemos en
purísima del rincón con una comunidad
muy marginada
es un centro comunitario que llevamos
muchos años manteniendo a través de la
empresa
charlatán botón y los que van
deshaciendo si armar un carro tal toma
es lo que me llama mucho la atención
empezar con los niños que son el futuro
de este país en donde podemos todavía
impactar influenciar en sus actitudes en
sus sus valores
[Música]
en el centro comunitario no esperanza
recibimos niños entre 4 y 15 años nos
apoyamos con sus tareas clases de
regularización de lo que llevan en la
escuela normal bien les damos una comida
diaria muchas veces la única que hacen
el día
[Música]
y aparte regularizada los que están con
problemas de aprendizaje humanos la zona
estamos una zona extremadamente marginal
entonces lo que yo quiero es darle a los
niños de esperanzas de crear con
diferencia a mí me ha servido muchísimo
muchísimo la escuelita porque pues ellos
miren con mucha interactividad y aquí
sacan toda la energía buenos hacer cosas
productivas alejarlos de los vicios de
las adicciones
estamos en actividades de investigación
de proyectos innovadores y hacemos lo
que le llamamos la feria de ciencias
vengo desde los 7 años trabajo aprendo
más me está minando mucho del prd
fernando para que supiera y a veces
también adelantaba más para que yo
estuviera adelantado
sudán en ajedrez una buena parte de sus
papás y mis nietos son felices queremos
que con uno de estos 150 o 200 niños que
apoyamos con uno que salvemos día ya es
una batalla ganada
actualmente gracias
solo estoy involucrado en estos dos
proyectos uno es el centro comunitario
cuando venía de camino con don ramón
asensio me platica de su experiencia se
decidió retirar y quiso acercarse con
los vecinos de por donde él vivía con
los niños y muy inocentemente don ramón
pensó que iba a traerlos con clases de
catecismo
duraron un par de días asistiendo y al
tercer día su desinterés y dejaron de
asistir después me platicaba que trato
de enseñarles oficios a los niños para
los que tuvieran ciertas herramientas si
quería buscar un trabajo y que
aprendieran a hacer algo
pero el día que les dijo mañana nos
vemos para entrenar fútbol llegaron los
vecinos los primos de los vecinos los
amiguitos 80 niños en la cancha
este programa se llama su futuro soñar
sobresalir socializar solidaridad
sonreír a través del fútbol fútbol es el
gancho
actualmente yo le dedico
23 horas diarias a los niños entre
entrenamientos los sábados los llevó
consigo partidos porque es como la
motivación de que sigan entrenando me
gusta competir
antes de cada entrenamiento los ponemos
a recoger basura para que dejen el campo
en óptimas condiciones tienen que
recoger se les inculca del reciclaje
reutilizar no el uso del plástico
etcétera etcétera la anatomía
mientras estiramos o calentamos les
platicamos de huesos y músculos
importantes del cuerpo
matemáticas y geografía se estaban
preguntando como en la cancha les
inculcan matemáticas y geografía
matemáticas con dinámicas muy sencillas
de competencia se les asignan números
por ejemplo y hacemos cálculo mental no
todo en la cancha todo con el balón
geografía
después de los entrenamientos previos
por ejemplo a qué equipo le vas tú no
datos al real madrid al barcelona dónde
está dónde juega real madrid en españa
dónde está españa en europa la última
vez uno me dijo que cuando los lleva de
europa entonces ya lo trató de hacer un
poco más local con equipos del fútbol
mexicano
que eso contar una anécdota
una vez llegaron después del
entrenamiento un grupo de niños muy
sospechosos que me estaban preguntando
profe usted que le gusta comer que usted
que come normalmente y yo en mi papel de
buen ejemplo yo les dije no pues yo
trato de meter en mis comidas proteínas
verduras algo saludable y pizza y
hamburguesas eso no le gusta mucho pues
si de repente los fines de semana pues
no pasa nada si comenzaron la semana
pues te echas una pizza o algo me llevé
la sorpresa
a la semana pusieron en un salón globos
se cooperaron estos niños de las
comunidades para un pastel y que otra
cosa creen
pizzas por mi cumpleaños sin duda el
cumpleaños más satisfactorio que tenía
en mi vida
hay dos posibles escenarios estos niños
en un futuro van a ser sus compañeros su
oferta laboral o van a ser los próximos
delincuentes
me llena de satisfacción cada día
levantarme
con estos niños convivir con ellos
y darles el ejemplo un ejemplo positivo
que es el que están buscando
así como digo en el vídeo con uno de
esos niños que salvemos ya es una
batalla ganada
el día de hoy con uno de ustedes que les
pueda transmitir y que salgan
convencidos y aportar en este sentido ya
cumplí mi objetivo señores
el balón está en su cancha está en sus
manos
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]